samedi 17 novembre à 00h59 c'est vrai
que j'ai vécu grâce à vous un grand
moment d'émotion puisque il y avait
balances ton post vous savez ma nouvelle
émission du vendredi soir on est en
direct on a reçu en plateau le petit
charlie qui est fait une vidéo dans
laquelle il racontait le harcèlement
scolaire dont il était victime vous a
préparé un magnéto pour tout vous
expliquer à propos de charlie regarder
tout le monde m'en a parlé ce week-end
est vraiment bien sûr je vais aller avec
le parc des princes s'il y avait
quelqu'un qui veut venir avec nous je
vous invite bien surtout elle viendrait
avec moi en série leproux à 700 milles
on à 516 milles mais il reste quand même
quelque chose c'est qu'ils avaient le
match de foot avant sur tf1 qui s'est
terminée un peu tôt il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont venus après le foot nous
voir donc encore mais c'est grâce aussi
à tf1 d'ailleurs merci tf1 vendredi soir
sur le plateau de balances ton post il
fallait être solide pour ne pas fondre
en larmes devant l'histoire
bouleversante de charlie ce petit garçon
au visage d'ange devenue un symbole du
harcèlement scolaire depuis la
publication de cette vidéo
charlie a réussi à donner un visage à ce
fléau qu'est le harcèlement les
chroniqueurs et cyril n'ont pas caché
leur émotion
moi tu sais que je suis là c'est à le
moindre problème nous aussi on est là on
t'aime petit homme sort et pour
remercier le petit garçon de son courage
et de sa gentillesse cyril avait même
prévu une petite surprise pour charlie
fans de soprano qui t'a mis en cause au
chanteur sommes très le safem utile si
tu regardes samu sarni salut charline là
c'est surprenant c'est une grande à
l'intérieur et que j'espère qu'on se
verra bientôt en tout cas ce qu'a fait
des bises à toi et à ta maman et à tout
moment et charlie a profité de son tout
premier passage télé pour faire une
déclaration à son amoureuse le courageux
charlie à porter dignement ce combat sur
le devant de la scène
une occasion de rappeler qu'il existe
des solutions lorsqu'on est victime de
harcèlement scolaire
[Musique]
voilà
c'est vrai que c'était vraiment un
moment exceptionnel que j'ai passé grâce
à charlie et si vous voulez réagir
oui j ce qui est formidable c'est il
faut qu'il faut parler et lui et lui qui
est si jeune comme ça il parle avec
courage il parle publiquement c'est très
compliqué mais il faut que la parole se
libère il est l'exemple même de ce qu'il
faut faire pour les autres et pour lui
donc non seulement il est courageux mais
il est altruiste et généreux 5 et beau
temps mais c'est surtout ses idées ne
sont abstraites souvent la plupart du
temps leur scellement l'école les
violences faites aux femmes et quand on
a quelqu'un qui peut le personnaliser au
nom de tous les autres bah c'est encore
plus ou moins con plus fort donc le
brave houcine de l'avoir reçu alors non
mais nous on essaie très heureux de le
recevoir et ceram aussi on a eu un autre
témoignage vraiment poignant vous avez
vu de harcèlement avec sandrine voilà
qui étaient avec nous